I don't understand anything when it
comes to playing chess out loud I was
friends with this guy that was in prison
mm-hmm and in prison he learned how to
play chess with his words you know with
it just in his head and he was at this
place that we used to play pool at in
White Plains New York's called executive
billiards a classic old-school pool hall
yeah I think it's done now I think they
they just closed it down or something
like that maybe they're renovating or
something but this guy was playing with
this kid who was like a world champion
chess player and this kid would come by
and play pool this really young kid like
like 15 16 years old and the two of them
were sitting there playing chess with
each other like just saying you know
Knight to Queen 2 or you know whatever
the fuck it means and the guy would go
stand there go rook 2 6 ba ba ba and
they would go back and forth like this
I'm bill I was like what are you like
I'm imagining what they're seeing like
what are they seeing in their head
are they seeing like these things move
around in three dimensions are they
looking at it as a grid how are they
keeping track or where their fucking
pieces are it was humbling humbling no
that's just reject mine that I do not
have what was interesting to me too
because there's a very young man I think
it was like 23 or 24 I got to see how
fucking smart this guy was yet he still
wound up in prison mmm I was like okay
just because someone's a criminal
doesn't mean they're stupid and just
because someone's smart doesn't mean
they won't go to jail absolutely those
are two things I saw talking to that guy
and if he was in the middle of the game
once and he was gambling with this guy
and this is the guy from prison it was
super smart guy very sharp guy and he
was talking to the guy who's playing he
said dude my wife told me if I don't get
home by 10:00 she wants a divorce and
ten o'clock rolls around and he yells
out I guess I'm getting a divorce
two hours later he just racks the balls
he was there to like two o'clock in the
morning but it was hilarious he just he
said like as they started playing my
wife says if I don't come home by 10:00
those are weird times man growing up in
like a suburb of
Boston which was a really nice place I
grew up in this place called Newton like
real quiet quaint little community to go
from that like these seedy pool halls of
New York was really weird for me
very very educational I got to see all
these like street hustlers I got to hang
around with these guys be friends with a
lot of homeless guys like I had guys
that were like pool players that wound
up staying on my couch they had nowhere
to go you know a couple of them and one
of them who became my best friend this
guy named Johnny but it was like we'd be
in all these weird places gambling like
his weird strange places with these guys
who were like these semi-professional
players playing for hundreds thousands
of dollars and it'd be a big crowd of
guys all gathered around it'd be 1 2 in
the morning and I'd be thinking these
guys these are older than me men like
they don't have families like what do
they do like this is a whole separate
culture you know when you're in that
underwear oh it was in a lot of ways men
a lot of ways it was very underworld II
I was obsessed with it two men I just
wanted to play pool all the time I
wasn't very good but the guys that was
around were very good I was around a lot
of guys were very would very very good
and you got to see like the excitement
of these it was like it wasn't just
excitement that everybody was gathered
around mm-hmm and that they were playing
this game for a lot of money it was also
the excitement that we were bending the
rules we're all just a bunch of men
hanging out at this smokey place at one
o'clock in the morning on a Wednesday
and and everyone is in it together we're
all just in some way deranged derelicts
you know some weirdos from society that
can figure their way to be able to be at
this place at one o'clock in the morning
on a Wednesday like why the fuck are you
here man
I don't you have responsibilities no one
there had responsibilities everyone
there was some sort of either a
professional gambler or they had like
some one of the guys was a fireman who
they would they would put them on these
24 hour shifts and they would have a
couple days off you just come to pool
hall and hang out and watch guys gamble
so I mean it's not similar to understand
oh yeah man land the myth fits well
that's one of the reasons why I fit in
there from stand-up you know like
starting doing stand-up from 21 then
being around these pool hall guys when I
was like 23 or 24 I was like oh you guys
are like my fucked-up friends and I like
it's like too many people out there
think that there's like only one way to
live your life like there's a there's a
bunch of ways to live life there's a lot
yeah it's a whole lot of world and
everybody wants you to think that their
way of living life is the way you should
go about it it's real tricky because
they all want like this sort of
confirmation bias they want they want
you to confirm they want well it's more
like a confirmation desire they want you
to confirm that they're doing the right
thing if you listen to them then you
become happy and you know they come up
to you and they go hey man I'm really
really excited that you you told me how
to do it this way because now I'm just
living my life much better thank you
very much
people love to hear that like yeah I'm
right then I am living my life the right
way
there's no right way